want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more
inside you too you've got michael jordan
level genius at something so today let's
live your best believe
life and get the best video for elon
musk motivation
enjoy
young people globally who want to be
like elon musk
what's your advice to them i think
that probably they shouldn't want to be
you i think it sounds better than it is
okay
um yeah it's
uh not as much fun being me as you'd
think
i don't know you don't think so there's
definitely it could be worse for sure
but it's um i i
i'm not sure i would i'm not sure i want
to be me
okay but
if
you know i think advice i mean if you
want to make
progress in things i think that
um but the best analytical framework
for understanding the future is physics
i'd recommend studying the uh
the thinking process around physics like
not just not not the equations i mean
equations certainly they're helpful
but the the the way of thinking in
physics is
the it's the best framework for
understanding things that are
counterintuitive
and you know always taking the position
that you are some degree wrong and your
goal is to be less wrong over time
one of the biggest mistakes people
generally make and i'm guilty of it too
is wishful thinking
you know like you want something to be
true even if it isn't true um
and so you ignore the things that uh
you ignore the real truth because of
what you want to be true
um this is a very difficult trap to
avoid
and like i said certainly one that i
find myself
in having problems with
but if you just take that approach of
you're always to some degree wrong
and your goal is to be less wrong and
and solicit critical feedback
particularly from friends like friends
particularly friends
if somebody loves you they want the best
for you they don't want to tell you the
bad things
so you have to ask them you know and
said really i
really do want to know and then they'll
tell you
you don't need college learning learn
stuff okay
everything is available basically for
free you can learn anything you want
for free it is not a question of
learning
um there there is a value that colleges
have which is like
you know seeing whether somebody's is
can somebody work hard at something
including a bunch of sort of annoying
homework assignments
and still do their homework assignments
uh
and and kind of soldier through and and
get it done
you know that's that's like the main
value of college and then also you know
if you you
probably want to hang around with a
bunch of people your own age for a while
instead of going right into the
workforce um
so i think colleges are basically for
fun and to prove you can do your chores
but they're not for learning
i think failure is bad um i don't think
it's good um
but if if if something's important
enough then you
you do it even though the risk of
failure is high um
and and so i think my advice if somebody
wants to start a company is
they should bear in mind that the most
likely outcome is is that it's not going
to work
and they should reconcile themselves to
that past
strong possibility and they should only
do it if they feel that they
they're they're really compelled to do
it you know
um because it's it's
it's gonna the way starting company
works is like usually in the beginning
it's
the very beginning it's kind of fun um
and then
it's really hellish for a number of
years
you talked about chewing glass yeah
there's
there's a friend of mine who's a
successful entrepreneur and
started actually his career around the
same time as i did and he has a good
good good phrase his name's bully uh um
he said yeah
you're starting companies like eating
glass and staring into the abyss
and you agree with that generally true
um yeah and and and if you don't eat the
glass you're not going to be successful
also if you want to have more self
belief and more self confidence i've
created a special
free program where every day for the
next 254 days i will send you
an unlisted video to help you boost your
self-belief and self-confidence the link
to join for free
is in the description below there are
just times when
something is important enough you
believe in it enough that
you you do it in spite of fear when you
want to do something new
you you have to you have to apply the
the physics approach
well we have a lot of good good people
at spacex that
um a lot of really talented people
uh in fact i wonder like sometimes
how we can make use of their talents in
the best way
because you know i think we're often not
using their talents in the best way
um
yeah but you know to the point of the
question i was just asked i want to make
sure
tesla recruiting does not have anything
that says requires
university because that's absurd
but there is a requirement of evidence
of exceptional ability
like you just can't if you're trying to
do something exceptional they must have
evidence of exceptional ability i don't
consider going to college
evidence of exceptional ability in fact
ideally you dropped out and did
something
i mean obviously you know we just look
at like you know
gates is a pretty smart guy he dropped
down
john was pretty smart he dropped out you
know larry ellison
a smart guy he dropped out i'm like
obviously not needed
so did shakespeare even go to college
probably not
but one of the fun things for me is
watching the the cargo go into the crew
vessel you know all of a sudden we had
dragon one now we have crew dragon and
it's substantially different but
familiar so tell us like what's been
some of the hardest parts to transition
from cargo
into crew because crew is a little more
important
than than cargo yes i mean cargo can be
replaced
crew cannot um and so the the level of
scrutiny the level of attention
is i mean i don't know order of
magnitude greater
it was it was it was already high for
cargo i mean
and and uh but it's it's just a whole
nother level for
for a crew um so you know after and
after i told the
spacex team that you know the uh
this mission reliability is not really
the top priority it is the only priority
right now
um so we're just doing continuous uh
engineering reviews
uh from now non-stop uh 24 hours a day
until launch
just gone over everything again and
again and again and i was out at the pad
just recently just walking down the
rocket
um we've got a team that's just crawling
over the rocket in the horizontal
then we're gonna rotate it vertical then
we're gonna crawl all over in the
vertical
and we're just looking for
any any possible action that can improve
the probability of success no matter how
small
whether that comes from an intern or me
or anyone it doesn't matter
what sort of things do you look for in
people or in processes that make the
workforce better
sure well i think the massive
thing that can be done is to make sure
your incentive structure is such that
innovation is rewarded and lack of
innovation is punished
they've got to be a characteristic so uh
if somebody is innovating um
and doing making good progress
then they should be promoted sooner
and if somebody is completely failing to
innovate
not every role requires innovation but
if they're
in a role where innovation is
should be happening and it's not
happening then they should
either not be promoted or exited and let
me tell you you'll get promoted you
could
you'll you'll get innovation real fast
so now your actual total mass
of a steel uh
of a reusable steel spacecraft is less
than that of the most advanced carbon
fiber
vehicle you could possibly imagine yeah
wow but this happened by accident by the
way this may sound like some
great insight but it actually happened
because we were moving too slowly on
composite
um and i was like we cannot move this
slowly or we'll go bankrupt
so just do this with steel
so yeah i mean the design has to be
focused on problem solving otherwise
you're going to spend too much time
trying to figure
you don't start with a yeah yeah i'm
like
sort of taken to management management
by rhyming if the schedule is
your schedule is long your design is
wrong right
this is very true that's good good point
yes
advice i'd give to people starting
company to entrepreneurs in general is
um really focus on making a product that
your customers love
um and it's so rare that you can buy a
product and and you love the product
when you bought it
this is this is there are very few uh
things that fit into that category
and if you can come up with something
like that your business will be
successful for sure
tesla really faced the severe uh threat
of death
due to the model 3 production ramp
essentially
the company was bleeding money like
crazy and and just
if if we didn't solve these problems in
a very short period of time
we would die and it was extremely
difficult to solve them
how close to death did you come we were
within
single-digit weeks 22 hours a day like
what how many hours working yeah
seven days a week sleeping in the
factory uh i worked away from the i
worked in the
paint shop general assembly body shop
you ever worry about yourself
imploding like it's just too much
absolutely no one should
put this many hours into work
this is not good and people should not
work this hard i'm not
they should not do this this is very
painful
painful in what sense it's because my
ears my brain
and my heart so it's this is not
recommended for anyone i just did it
because
if i didn't do it then tesla good chance
as it would die
the real way i think you you actually
achieve intellectual property protection
is by innovating fast enough if your
rate of innovation
is high then you don't need to worry
about protecting
vip because other companies will be
copying something that you did years ago
and that's fine you know
just make sure your rate of innovation
is fast
um speed is really the speed of
innovation is what is what matters
um and i do i do say this to my teams
like
quite a lot that innovation per unit
time as i go
innovation per year if you're what i say
like is is what matters not
innovation absent time because
if you wanted to make say um 100
improvement in something
and that took 100 years or one year
that's
radically different so
it's like what is your rate of
innovation that that matters and is the
rate of innovation
is that accelerating or decelerating
um and a weird thing happens when
companies get big is that
most companies or organizations the
bigger they get
they tend to get less innovative
not just less innovative on a per person
basis but less innovative in the
absolute
and i think this is probably because the
incentive structure is not
uh is not there for
innovation um
it's not enough to use words to
encourage innovation
the incentive structure must be aligned
with that
that's fundamental you need to work if
depending on how
well you want to do and particularly if
you're starting a company you need to
work super hard
so what what does super hard mean well
when my brother and i were starting our
first company
instead of getting an apartment we just
rented a small office and we slept on
the couch
and we we showered at the the ymca and
uh we're so hot up we had just one
computer so
the the the website was up during the
day
and i was coding at night seven days a
week all the time
and i i sort of briefly had a girlfriend
in that period and in order to
be with me she had to sleep in the
office so
i work hard like
it i mean every waking hour that's
that's the the thing i would i would say
if if you're particularly if you're
starting a company um
and i mean if you do simple math say
like okay if somebody else is working 50
hours and you're working 100
you'll get twice as done as much done in
the course of a year as
the other company i think of the these
things is just
there's a certain amount of time and
within that time
you want the the best net
outcome so for
you know all the set of actions that you
can do there's
going to be uh and some of which will
fail some which will succeed
and you want the the net useful
output of your set of actions to be the
highest
so
um i'm going to like use like a baseball
analogy like
you know baseball they don't let you
just sit there and wait for the perfect
pitch
until that you get a real easy one they
didn't give you
three shots and the third one they say
okay
they get off the go back to the
put somebody else up there um so these
your three strikes on on
baseball um not
you know not only bad anymore so
so you're what you're really looking for
is like what's the batting average
you know how how are you doing on uh
on score um and just
there's going to be some amount of
failure
but you want your net output um
that useful output to be maximized
failure is
essentially irrelevant unless it is
catastrophic
don't just follow the trend so um
you may have heard me say that it's good
to think in terms of
the physics approach of first principles
which is
rather than reasoning by analogy you
boil things down to
the most fundamental truths you can
imagine and you reason up from there
and this is a good way to figure out if
if something really makes sense or if
it's just
what everybody else is doing
it's hard to think that way you can't
think think that way about everything
it takes a lot of effort uh but if
you're trying to do something new
it's the best way to think um and that
framework was developed
by by physicists to figure out
counterintuitive things
like quantum mechanics so it's really a
powerful
powerful method we need to push for
radical breakthroughs
um and if you don't push for radical
breakthroughs
you're not going to get radical outcomes
um
and that that does mean taking risks um
and yeah common sense that the the
if you take a big risk in order to have
a big reward there must be a big risk
it's most the time you cannot find a
big reward for small risk that's why
those are rare
so you're going to have some
proportionality with the risk and reward
i simplify your product as much as
possible
um
you know and then like if i think of
some of the ways which how does a smart
engineer make dumb mistakes
including you know
is optimize something that shouldn't
exist
don't optimize something that shouldn't
exist um but people are trained to do
this in college
you can't say no to the professor you
know the professor's going to give you
the
exam and you've got to answer all the
questions
or they'll get angry
so and give you a bad grade so then you
you always optimize the you always
answer the question
a lot of the times you should say this
is the wrong question
right in fact the question is definitely
wrong to some degree just how wrong
and i think just generally taking the
approach that
your design is some degree wrong
probably a lot more than you think your
goal is to make it less wrong over time
zip2 started off as basically
like say we're trying to figure out how
to how to make enough money to
exist as a company and the
so so since there wasn't really any
advertising money being made
we thought we could um help existing
companies
get online bring their stuff online so
we developed software that
helped bring um love in newspapers and
media companies online because they
alone just didn't
they also didn't know what the internet
was they were big customers didn't you
yeah
and even the ones that were aware of the
internet didn't have a software team so
they
could they weren't very good at
developing functionality
um and uh so we had as um investors and
customers
uh the new york times company night
reader host and and so we were able to
get them to pay us to develop software
for them to bring them online so online
publishing stuff
we did maps and directions and yellow
pages and white pages and
various other things 2008 in particular
was was
was awful because we had the third
launch failure in a row
of of our falcon 1 vehicle at spacex
um and um
we the tesla financing round that we
were
raising fell apart um because the
economy is going to tailspin
um and it's pretty hard to raise money
for a startup
car company uh you know late 2008 when
gm and chrysler are busy going bankrupt
um that was that was tough and then
solar city had to deal with uh morgan
stanley and morgan stanley had to renege
on the deal because they themselves were
running out of money
um so it looked like all three companies
were gonna die and
i was also going through divorce so that
was definitely a low point
so it's 2008 you're going through a
divorce which like some
to borrow your word douchebag vloggers
are writing about to make even worse
right yes that's true um in addition to
all that stuff happening i was getting
dumped on
massively in the press right yeah you're
you know it looks like all three
companies
yeah are going to file i mean why do you
keep going with all three
like i feel like even a lot of great
entrepreneurs in that situation would
have been like
i've already sunk everything i have in
these companies
and i gotta pick one but you didn't i
mean you kept doing all three
why um yeah that was that was a very
tough call
um at the end of 2008 that was that was
probably the top
you know one of the toughest goals i've
had to make because i could either
um reserve capital for one
company or the other i mean before solar
city didn't need a ton of capital so
they were okay um but between spacex and
and and tesla um
you know it's sort of like like you've
got two kids and
what do you do do you spend all your
money to to maximize probably the
success of
of one or do you do you try to keep both
left
unfortunately it worked how aside from
making great products how do you get
people
excited about tesla there's a lot of
people i know and that i talk to who are
just
intrigued and interested and excited
about tesla as a company
the thing i really focus on at tesla is
like we
really put all of our money into an
attention to trying to make the product
as compelling as possible
so um because i think that really the
way to
um sell any product is through word of
mouth so if if
one somebody gets the car they really
like it they and and
actually the key is like to have a
product that people love
um and and general people um
you know if that a party or tour friends
or whatever
um you'll talk about the things that you
love but
you know if you just like something it's
okay you're not going to care that much
but if you look at the reactions from
the highs and the lows you're gonna yeah
you're gonna talk you know and and then
that'll generate work turns word of
mouth
that's basically how how our sales have
have grown like we don't we're not
spending money on advertising or
endorsements or
uh and um so anyone like buys our car
they just water because they they like
the car zip2 happened
you sold it and it and bought the
mclaren
and if i'm not mistaken you you invested
most of that money
into your next uh your next venture uh
x.com
that's right um so uh yeah most of most
of the funds went into x.com which was
later renamed paypal that worked out
pretty well
[Music]
it worked out pretty well but looking
looking back on it um
would because you put a lot of your eggs
in in that basket
would you would you advise entrepreneurs
to
roll the bones quite the way you did
yeah absolutely i think so
um i think i think i think it's worth
investing
your own capital in what you do i don't
believe in the
sort of other people's money thing um
you know i think
if you're not willing to put your own
assets at stake then you shouldn't ask
other people to do that to do that
we don't think too much about what
competitors are doing yeah um
just because i think it's important to
um be
just focused on making the best possible
uh products
um you know it's sort of maybe analogous
to
what they say about you know if you're
in a in a if you're if you're in a
in a race um don't worry about what how
the
what the other runners are doing just
run what is the likelihood that you
personally will go to mars
70 we've recently made a number of
breakthroughs that i
that i'm just really fired up about and
when does that happen
in our lifetimes yeah yeah i'm talking
about moving there so it's like so if it
can get the price per ticket maybe
around a couple hundred thousand dollars
this could be an escape hatch for rich
people
no if your probability of dying on mars
is much higher than earth
really the app would go to mars would be
like shackleton's after going to the
antarctic
it's going to be hard there's a good
chance of death
going in a little can through deep space
you might
land successfully once you land
successfully there will be
a map you'll be working non-stop to
build the base
uh series you're not not much time for
leisure and once you get there even
after doing all this
there's a very harsh environment to use
a good chance to die there
we think you can come back but we're not
sure now does that sound like an escape
patch for rich people
and yet you would unhesitate and wake up
you know there's lots of people like
climb
mountains you know why they climb
mountains because people die on
endeavors all the time
they're like doing it for the challenge
it's very important to to seek out
to actively seek out and listen very
carefully
to negative feedback and this is
something that people tend to
avoid because it's it's painful yeah um
but but i think this is a very common
mistake
is to to not actively seek out
and listen to uh negative feedback what
do you do that you go into forums do you
go into twitter like what are your
areas where you go to look for feedback
on let's say the tesla well
it's like everyone i talk to is um in
fact when um
when friends get a product i say look i
don't tell me what you like tell me what
you don't like
right um and and because otherwise your
friend is not going to tell you what he
doesn't like
right this girl's going to say oh i love
this and that and and then
and leave out the this is the stuff i
don't like list because too much of your
friend want you know
it doesn't want to offend you so um
so you really need to
[Music]
to to to to sort of coax negative
feedback
um and you should you know that if
somebody is your
is your friend or at least not your
enemy and they're giving you negative
feedback
um then they may be wrong but it's
coming from a good place
and sometimes even your enemies give you
good negative feedback when i
started the first internet companies of
two
with my brother and another person um a
great curry
the uh it wasn't really with the thought
of being wealthy
you know nothing against being wealthy
but um
we'll get back to that later but it's
just it was just from the standpoint
i've been wanting to be part of
the internet and uh i i figured if we
could make enough money to
just get by it would be that'll be okay
um and when we started off uh
we we literally only had like one
computer and so it would be our web
server during the day and i'd code at
night
um and we we just got a a
a small office um in palo alto back when
rent was not
insane um and uh
it cost us like 450 a month it was
cheaper than an apartment so we actually
just slept in the office
and then [ __ ] and then showered the ymca
at page mill el camino
so we'd walk over there and and shower
and uh
and that was um actually i think uh
that was when i we first i first met you
by the way um and uh
so i don't know how many people probably
know many people know this but uh
uh we actually pitched uh steve in like
january 96
on uh the zip2 business plan uh and
actually i thought um she was
actually one of the most up to speed on
on what actually was in our business
plan most most people we met did not
actually read our business plan
um in fact a lot of people a lot of
venture capitalists who met at the time
didn't even
know what the internet was or they've
never used they've never used that
they're sure of them
right yeah i'm talking like you know
sort of well-known people in town here i
was like wow
okay um but at the time nobody made any
any money on the internet so
i guess that's um you know it then
it wasn't really clear evidence that
there was was a business i mean i should
say that you know when i was a kid i
didn't really have any grand designs
i mean the reason i started programming
computers is because
i like computer games um and i play lots
of computer games
and um i learned that if i wrote
software and sold it then i could get
more money and buy better computers
so it wasn't really you know with some
grand vision or anything
when i was growing up i'd read lots of
books and
they were very often set in the united
states and
it seemed like a lot of new technology
was being developed in the united states
so
i i thought okay i really want to work
on new technology
so i want to get to silicon valley um
you know which when i was growing up
silicon valley seemed like some sort of
mythical place
uh you know like mount olympus or
something
i came conclusion that um my initial
premise was was wrong
uh that in fact the um
there's there's a great deal of will uh
you know that there there's there's not
such a shortage
um but people don't think there's a way
um
and and that if people thought there was
there was a way or do something that
wouldn't
break the federal budget um then then
people
would support it um which in retrospect
i think is actually
kind of obvious because um the
the united states is a distillation of
the human spirit of exploration
people came here from other places um i
mean it's
you know there's no nation there's no i
mean there's no nation that that's more
a nation of explorers than united united
states but
but people need to believe that it's
possible and it's that it's not
you know it's they're not going to give
up like healthcare or something
important
you know it's just it's got to be that
that that's important so
so i thought okay well then it's not a
question of will it's a question of
showing that there's a way
in the beginning nobody wanted a tesla i
can tell you that
the the the when we made the original
sort of roads to the sports car uh
people were like
why would i want an electric car that's
my gasoline
car works fine i'm like no electric cars
better try it
um and it was you know
hard to get people to do a test drive
first one
nobody knew who we were and then we
heard this company and like yeah we're
named after nikola tesla you know that
guy nope
um so
for sure we were doing push in the
beginning because people said
there was no one telling us that they
wanted an electric car so it was not it
was not out of like
you know it's like lots of people coming
up to me saying hey i really want
electric car
i heard that zero times um
some people like it's like man we're
gonna make an electric car and show that
these things can be good
um and then people want them um
you know it's like i think it was like
henry ford said that like the you know
we're talking about the model t it's
like if you ask the public what they
wanted they'd say
a faster horse so if you did like a big
survey and say
well hey public before automobiles
what would you like it's like well i'd
like my horse to go three miles an hour
faster
and eat less food and
you know be stronger and live longer and
like i think
um there will be basically a bunch of
incremental improvements on horse
um because people when you say like what
about an automobile that car that drives
itself like what are you talking about
that's that sounds crazy um but
when you actually make an automobile and
give it to people and say okay
now this is a horse where you can keep
it in the barn and if you leave for a
month it's still alive
yeah so carry more
more weight than a horse and go further
and that kind of thing so
yeah it's like when when it's a
radically
new product people don't know that they
want it because it's just not in their
in their scope i think when they first
started making tvs
they did a nationwide survey i think
this might have been like
46 or 48 it's like famous nationwide
survey
will you ever buy a tv now it was like
96 percent of respondents said no
some crazy number like basically
everyone's like would you buy a tv
and maybe they put a price in there or
something i don't know but it was
famously almost everyone said they would
not buy tv
but they didn't know what they're
talking about so the big game-changing
stuff at the beginning
is a company push kind of a thing most
of the time
but then changes to the product over
time can be
a lot more customer pull kind of a focus
yeah changes the product over time can
be
incremental changes then
the customers can certainly tell you
it's good to get customer feedback to
say
how can we improve the product um
and once they're using it they can say
okay i like this thing about it
i don't like this other thing and then
we can improve the product over time
customer feedback after they they have
the fundamental thing is is great when
trying different things
you you got to have some acceptance of
failure as you're alluding to earlier
failure must be an option if failure is
not an option it's going to result in
extremely conservative choices
and you may not may get something even
worse than
lack of innovation things may go
backwards
so if what you really want is
uh risk risk
to you you want reward and punishment to
be proportionate to the actions that you
seek
so if uh if what you're seeking is
innovation
then you should reward success and
innovation
um and only
[Applause]
there should be minor consequences for
lack of
minor consequences for for trying and
failing
should that should be minor um
significant rewards for trying and
succeeding
minor consequences for trying and not
succeeding
and big and major negative consequences
for not
trying or maybe i just blank out the
word doubt
so uh you know i mean i totally frank i
doubted us too
so i i thought we you know had maybe
when starting spacex maybe had a 10
chance of reaching orbit so
so you know to those who who doubted us
i was like well i think you're probably
right
you know um i mean there were times uh
that i was told like uh because i was
taking the
money that i learned from from paypal
and enrolling into
to create spacex and tesla and and they
ended up spending it all
it wasn't the intention but um
and and and uh almost both companies
went bankrupt frankly 2008 was a tough
year
um you know took us took us four
attempts just to get to orbit with
falcon one
um and uh so
but a lot of times i was you know i
people would tell me this joke like
how do you make a small fortune in the
rocket industry you start with a large
one is the
punch line and i was like okay i already
heard that joke 12
000 times you know
so anyway um and it was it almost came
true
[Music]
you know we just barely made it there
that fourth launch
of falcon one that's all the money we
had for that fourth launch
and then uh and that wasn't even enough
to save the company we also then had to
win the nasa cargo resupply contract
um so that that came a little after you
know a little bit later
or towards the end of 2008 uh those are
the two
key things that that saved spacex
otherwise we would have we would have
you know not made it so
um so hey i think those those doubters
were
their probability assessment was correct
um but fortunately
uh veda smiled upon us and brought us to
this day
as you look back on your career in the
space industry what has been the most
surprising or unexpected challenge that
you faced
and along those lines if you were to go
back in time and talk to your 20 year
old self
would you do anything differently
go back in time to your 20 year old self
i mean i think i'd if i could i think it
would make
far fewer mistakes obviously if i could
go like here's a list of all the dumb
things you're about to do please do not
do them
yeah wouldn't we all be a very long list
and like you know
here let me write it down or something
you know
um i mean it's hindsight's 2020. so it's
hard to say
um i mean a number of i've made so many
foolish mistakes i had a lot count
honestly um
i mean some of these things i just wish
i like like that's
simple sort of mantra management by
rhyming
i mean it worked for homer okay um
management by rhyming is
the thing i'm saying like if but if the
schedule's long the design is wrong
we've overcomplicated the design many
times
and i think we should have just gone
with a simpler design
with the acid test being how long will
it take to
for this to fly and if it's going to
take a long time
don't do it do something else i think
one thing that's important
is if you have a choice of a lower
evaluation
with someone you really like or a higher
evaluation with someone you have a
question mark about
take the lower valuation um it's better
to have
a higher quality venture capitalist
who you think is it would be great to
work with than to
um you know get a higher evaluation
with someone where there's even a
question mark really
you know i think that's that's important
it's sort of like getting married you
know
i mean the way i tend to view problems
is from a from a physics
standpoint and i think i think physics
is a good analytical framework
um and one of the key things in in
physics is to reason from first
principles
um this is contrary to the way most
human reasoning takes place which is by
analogy
um reason for first principles just
means that you you figure out
what are the fundamental what are the
fundamental truths or
or things that are pretty people are
pretty sure are fundamental truths
and and can you build up to a conclusion
from
from that uh or you know perform those
principles
and um and then certainly if you come up
with some idea
and it appears to violate one of those
fundamental
truths then you're probably wrong um or
you should get a really big prize or
something like that
um so uh this may seem like i don't know
it maybe it may seem
sort of obvious when it's explained but
it's actually not what people do
reasoning my analogies is helpful
because it's a shortcut yeah um
and it's and it's mostly correct but but
uh it tends to be
most incorrect when you're dealing with
new things because
it's hard to analyze to something really
new it doesn't really face to severe
uh threat of death due to the model 3
production ram
essentially the company was bleeding
money like crazy and
and just if if we didn't solve these
problems in a very short period of time
we would die and it was extremely
difficult to solve them
how close to death did you come we were
within
single digit weeks 22 hours a day like
what how many hours working yeah so
seven days a week
sleeping in the factory uh i worked
everywhere from i worked
in the paint shop general assembly body
shop you ever worry about yourself
imploding like it's just too much
absolutely no one should
put this many hours into work
this is not good and people should not
work this hard i'm not
they should not do this this is very
painful
painful in what sense it's because my
ears my brain
and my heart and you started with a much
smaller rocket of talking one
and was your goal at that point when you
started with falcon 1 to get to the
point where we had nine inches for
falcon 9 was that your goal at that time
when i started spacex i i only thought
there was maybe a ten percent chance of
getting felt from one to august i did
not at all think that this would happen
uh so let's just make sure our dream
come true um
uh but i i literally at the time i
didn't know anything about rockets uh
and i was
you know i've been the chief engineer of
spacex since day one
and i don't really hear anything about
rockets which is why the first three
rockets failed right
um and then so the first three falcon
ones for space section
failures yes and then tell me about
uh the fourth one so
i had actually only had enough money for
three of three clients
um so i had no more money that would
manage to a team sort of rally
and we managed to put together enough
spare prices to pay them to do a fourth
launch
and that both was successful um and
uh so what would happen if it wasn't
successful oh we would
spacex for tonight so we would not be
here right now
uh at this moment getting ready to
launch crew dragon to the internet
we've got a lot of work to do because
we've got
a lot of service centers and charge
stations
to construct so mostly it's like we're
trying to build
our service and charge infrastructure as
fast as possible
um and uh i know this
like some of the customers who have
ordered a car they're not in
the major cities so they're all unhappy
with us because we are delaying delivery
of their car
um and uh in fact i'm going to apologize
to some of them personally
to explain the reason we are delaying
deliveries because
we really want them to have a good
experience but if they're too far from a
service center
and and the charging is not sorted out
then they will not have a good
experience
um so we're going to delay their cars
just for a few months to make sure that
they have a good experience
i think it's also important to reason
from first principles
rather than by analogy so the normal way
that we conduct our lives is we
we we reason by analogy it's we're doing
this because
it's like something else that was done
or it's like what
um other people are doing me too type
ideas
yeah it's like yeah slide iterations
yeah on on a theme
and and uh and it's
because it's it's kind of mentally
easier to reason by analogy
rather than from first principles but by
first principles is kind of a physics
way of
looking at the world and what that
really means is
you kind of boil things down to the most
fundamental truths
and and say okay what are we sure is
true or
sure as possible is true and then reason
up from there that takes a lot more
mental energy
um give me an example that like what's
one thing that you've you've done that
on that you feel has worked for you
sure so um somebody could say um
in fact people do uh that battery packs
are really
expensive and that's just the way
they'll always be because that's the way
they've been in the past
um you're like well no that's that's
pretty dumb
you know because if if you apply that
reasoning to
anything new that then
you wouldn't be able to ever get to that
new thing right
you are unusually fearless and willing
to go in the face of other people
telling you something is crazy and i
know a lot of
pretty crazy people you still stand out
uh where does that come from or how do
you think about
making a decision when everyone tells
you this is a crazy idea or where do you
get the internal strength to do that
well first of all i'd say i actually
think i i think i feel feel fear quite
strongly
um so it's not as though i just have the
absence of fear i've
i feel it quite strongly um but
there are just times when something is
important enough
you believe in it enough that you you do
it in spite of fear
so speaking of important things like
people shouldn't think i i i
i should if people should think well i
feel fear about this
and therefore i shouldn't do it um it's
normal to be
to feel fear like you'd have to
definitely something mentally wrong
if you didn't feel fear um
so you just feel it and let the
importance of it drive you to do it
anyway
yeah you know actually something that
can be helpful is fatalism
uh to some degree um if you just if just
accept the probabilities
um then that diminishes fear
so um starting spacex i thought the odds
of success were less than ten percent
um and i just accepted that actually
probably
i would just lose lose everything um
but that maybe would make some progress
if we could just move the ball forward
even if we died maybe some other company
could pick up the baton and move
and keep moving it forward so we still
do some good
yeah same with tesla i thought the odds
of a car company succeeding were
extremely low this is widely regarded as
one of the most robotics driven auto
assembly lines
on the planet elon part of the thing i
heard about the model 3 is that there's
too many robots that made it i
agree you do you think so too that maybe
you need more people in here working we
do
in some cases the robots actually slowed
the production yes they did we had this
crazy complex
network of conveyor belts and it was not
working so we got rid of that whole
thing
this is cool elon realizing it needed an
overhaul
musk personally took over the model 3
production line at the beginning
of april we're aiming for really extreme
levels of precision
more than any other vehicle in the world
he says he has resorted to pulling
all-nighters at the plant when things
get really intense
i don't have time to go home and shower
and change so i'd sleep here i want to
see where is that
oh yeah um i mean it's pretty boring
overall really um
it's actually cold in here too yeah i
like it cool so you have a
you like it cold i sleep on the couch
over there so you're just laying here
on the couch yeah last time this year i
actually slept literally on the floor
because the couch was too narrow
yeah i was gonna say and elon i have to
say it's not even a comfortable couch
either no it's terrible
this is not a good couch musk feels like
all the overtime is paying off
and now he says the model 3 line is back
on track
and we're able to un unlock some of the
critical things that are holding us back
from reaching 2000 cars a week but since
then we've continued to do 2000 cars a
week
do you think that this is sustainable
this pace
is sustainable yeah i remember when you
first told me that you were thinking
about tunnels
what did i first tell you about that
years ago okay it's like a long time ago
like i thought you were joking yeah it
was i was joking but
it's not because of some epiphany that i
had one day
driving down the 405.
that's how it gets translated somehow i
was talking about tunnels for years and
years
um for probably five years or four years
at least
whenever i'd give a talk and people
would ask me about what opportunities do
you see in the world i'd say tunnels can
someone please build tunnels
so after four or five years of begging
people to build tunnels
and still no tunnels i was like okay
i want to build a tunnel
like maybe i'm missing something here um
so um yes i was like basically talking
people's ears or tunnels for for several
years
and then said well let's find out what
it takes to build a tunnel
and um yeah so i started doing a tunnel
i wanted to start the tunnel uh from
where i could see it from my office at
spacex so i said well let's just
carve off a part of the parking lot
across the road so i can see if it's
if anything's happening or not
and then we named our first boring
machine uh godot
because i kept waiting for it it never
came
finally it um and and we got it going
and um now we're making a good progress
i
really take some thought to like how can
i provide advice that would be most
helpful and i'm not sure i've given
enough thought to
to that to give you the best possible
answer but i think
um i think certainly uh
being focused on something that you're
confident will have high value to
someone else
and just being really rigorous in making
that assessment
because people are tend to natural human
tendency is wishful thinking
so a challenge for entrepreneurs is to
say well what's the difference between
really believing in your ideals and
sticking sticking to them
versus pursuing some unrealistic dream
that
doesn't actually have merit and it's
it's that is a that is a really
difficult thing to
to tell you can you tell the difference
between those two things so you need to
be sort of
very rigorous in your self self analysis
um i think certainly extremely tenacious
uh and um and then just work like hell i
mean you just have to put in
you know 80 hour 80 to 100 hour weeks
every week
because and then a lot of work
all those things improve the odds of
success okay um
i mean if if other people are putting in
40 hour work weeks and you're putting
in 100 hour work weeks then even if
you're doing the same thing you know
that in in one year you will achieve
what they achieve
you will achieve in four months what it
takes them
a year to achieve this is the secret to
your success to be the ceo of two
companies at the same time
no i think it's just look at the
correlation
yeah struggling companies everything's
in the craft can in december 2008 so
let's take on a new ceo
gig yeah and same for steve coming back
to apple uh no it definitely was not my
intention to be co2 companies um
the uh i mean after i mean
i i there's certain things that i kind
of wanted to i thought were important to
happen
and i thought it was important that um
that there was
that that electric vehicle happened that
there was a success in the electric
vehicle arena
uh because the the incumbent companies
were
convinced that it was not possible to
create a an electric car that looked
good had
rain a good range performance and so
forth um
and that even if you did make such a car
it would not sell
because people had this love of gasoline
and so we had to show that
it was possible to create a compelling
electric car
long range good looking you know all
those things that was a tesla roadster
i certainly was quite um i was very very
bookish i was reading all the time so i
was either reading
uh working on my computer reading comics
playing dungeon dragons
uh that kind of thing and i understand
hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy
that wonderful book by douglas adams
that was a that was a key book for you
what was it about that book that that
fired your imagination
um yeah so uh i guess when i was
in around 12 or 13 i had a company
existential crisis and i was reading
various books
on trying to figure out the meaning of
life and well like what does it all mean
because
uh it starts seeming quite meaningless
and then
my we happen to have like some some
books by nietzsche and schopenhauer in
the house
which you should not read at age 14 is
bad
it's really negative um
so so uh but then i read the
hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy which
like quite positive i think and um
and it sort of highlighted the the an
important point which is
that a lot of times the question is
harder than the answer and if you can
properly phrase the question
then the answer is the easy part and so
the if to agree that we can better
uh understand the universe then we
better know what questions to ask
and then whatever the question is that
most approx
approximates what's the meaning of life
you know that
that's that's the question we could
ultimately get closer to
understanding um and so i thought well
to agree that we can expand the scope
and scale of consciousness
and knowledge
human knowledge then that would be a
good thing question that has been
discussed over the past couple of days
should we be considering
one trips one way only trips to mars
uh what's the best uh approach to to
colonize
uh the planet is it uh but what's your
view is that
socially acceptable do you think people
will sign up to do it i think there's
plenty of people who have signed up for
one retreat to mars
but maybe if i could we could have a
show of hands
who would consider such an option
i see some not many perhaps enough for a
couple of missions
so certainly beat up i mean i think it's
sort of like
is it a one-way mission and then you die
or is it
one-way mission and you get resupplied
that's a big
wait for the difference option yeah
exactly um
but i mean i think it ends up being a
moot point because
you want to bring the spaceship back
like these spaceships are expensive
okay if they're hard to build you can't
just leave them there
so whether or not people want to come
back or not is kind of like they can
jump on if they want but they need the
spaceship back
thank you
i mean kind of weird like there was like
a huge collection of spaceships on mars
over time
like it was like we should send them
back and of course we should be back
one of the most difficult choices i ever
faced uh in life
was was in 2008 um
and i think i had
like maybe 30 million dollars left
or 30 or 40 million left in 2008 i had
two choices
i could put it all into one company
and then the other company would
definitely die um or split it
between the two companies and but if i
split up between two companies then both
might die
um and when you put your
blood sweat and tears into creating
something you're building something it's
like a child
um and so
it's like which one am i going to let
one starve to death
i can bring myself to do it so i i split
the money between the two
fortunately thank goodness uh they both
came through i've heard people say
listen
he's out of the box thinker he's a
businessman he's an entrepreneur
but people that know you would say
i'm not really a business plan you're
not a businessman no no
what are you um i'm sure there's
probably lots of analysts
on wall street who agree that i'm not a
businessman okay well what do you think
you are
um i like i'm an engineer an engineer
yeah
is it your dream to conquer the world
and make the world a better place to
what is your dream like technology's
like magic you know
i mean i think technology is the closest
thing to magic that we have in the real
world
and so i think like engineering creative
engineering
is is essentially technology development
um
and uh i guess maybe it was like lord of
the rings is my favorite book
is it yeah that would be like what's the
closest thing to being a wizard
in the real world and that's like
creating new technologies what was your
biggest failure
and how did that change you i have to
really think hard about that
failure never heard of it
there's your answer um
well there's a ton of failures along the
way that's for sure
um like
as i said for spacex the first three
launches failed
and uh we were just barely able to
scrape
together enough parts and money to do
the
the fourth launch that fourth launch had
failed we would have been dead
so multiple failures along the way um
i tried very hard to to get the right
expertise in for
for spacex i tried hard to to find a
great
chief engineer for the rocket but not
the good chief engineers wouldn't join
and the bad ones well there was no no
point in hiring them so i ended up being
chief engineer of the rocket
so if i could have found somebody better
then we would have maybe had
less than three failures what
motivations do people need to harness to
try to make change as opposed to just
reading about
change um
and that's not supposed to be an easy
question oh it's it's this
well like i said i think if
if you study engineering and and you
figure out how to design new things
then it's relatively easy to start a
company
you just need to get a few like-minded
people with you
and then focus on creating a prototype
for compelling prototype as soon as
possible
um and then that you know there's a
there's a strong venture
uh capital industry in this in this
country that will give you funding to
take things to the next level
um and that that's all there is to it um
and you might
if you try it a few times you might may
or may not succeed but
um i think sometimes people fear fear
starting a company too much
um you know they have to say really
what's the worst that could go wrong
you're not going to stop to death
you're not going to die of exposure
what's the worst that could go wrong how
do you come with this idea actually
sometimes they're pushing the human
limit you are
always pushing the human limit why
well i
mean i i think about what what
technology solution
is necessary in order to achieve the
particular goal
and then try to make as much progress in
that direction being a multi-planet
species and being out there among the
stars is important for
the long-term survival of humanity
and that's one reason kind of like life
insurance for life collectively
life as we know it but then the part
that i find
personally most motivating is that
it creates a sense of adventure and it
makes people excited about the future
if you consider two futures one where we
are forever confined to earth
until eventually something terrible
happens
or another future where we are out there
on
many planets maybe even going beyond the
solar system
i think that second version is
incredibly exciting and inspiring
and there need to be reasons to get up
in the morning
you know life can't just be about
solving problems otherwise what's the
point
there's got to be things that people
find inspiring
and make life worth living there's a
friend of mine who's got a great saying
about
creating a company um which is
creating trying to build a company and
have it succeed is like eating glass and
staring into the abyss
so i mean what tends to happen is it's
sort of quite exciting for the first
several months of starting a company and
then
then reality sets in things don't go as
well as planned
customers aren't signing up the
technology or the product isn't working
as well as you thought
and i think that can sometimes be
compounded by a recession
and it can be very very painful for
several years
so i think frankly starting a company
i would advise people to have a high
pain tolerance when did it
occur to you that zip2 might be
a success well
i mean when we first started out i think
our ambitions were really quite
quite low um it was really to make
enough money to pay the rent
yeah we we got a visa to give us money
that was
yay we thought it was all over then yeah
it was pretty crazy i mean
when we started at 95 we literally at
the beginning we had one computer
which um would be the web server during
the day
and and then at night i'd program on it
um and we'd sleep in the office yeah we
couldn't afford to
yeah it was cheaper to rent the office
than to
rent an apartment so we just rented the
office and stepped in the office
and showered at the water ymca and for
me
the worst part was eating a
jack-in-the-box three times yeah man
this
is like it's really difficult to get
food at palo alto after
like 10 p.m um it's like jack in the box
and a few other options
we rotated through the jack-in-the-box
menu through through the end of 95 where
that's essentially we're just sleeping
in the office
and chairing the ymca and then um
and around the end of 95 is when
netscape went public and
and then whether or not somebody knew
what the internet was they knew that you
could make money on the internet somehow
or even if it's only on the greater pool
theory so
uh when we went and talked to venture
capitalists
in early 96 there was a much greater
um interest in what we were doing um in
fact
the round closed in like maybe a week or
something it's crazy yeah we went from
sleeping in the office to people
throwing i mean again this is a
financial crowd so you guys
see these numbers every day but for us
to here we'll give you three million
dollars
yeah sounded extremely we thought they
were crazy like why would they do that
it was literally like these people are
insane they obviously don't realize
we're sleeping in the office
in fact when they when they did fund us
they realized that
we were illegal immigrants well i'm sure
immigrants we were sleeping in the
office we didn't have a car we had one
car with the wheel kept falling off
but well actually yeah the the wheel
didn't actually fall off the car oh yes
exactly um
and the venture capitalists actually
bought us cars
yeah well like i gave us 40 grand it was
40 grand to go buy cars which was at the
time was more money than we've ever seen
yeah you need a team around you to
deliver
a lot of idea how do you choose your
team based on what
well i suppose honestly that
it tends to be gut feel more than
anything else
so when i interview somebody
my interview question is always the same
it's just
i said tell me the story of your life
and and the decisions that you made
along the way and why you made them
and then um
and also tell me about some of the most
difficult problems you worked on
and how you solved them and
that that question i think is very
important because
the people that really solve the problem
they know
exactly how they solved it they know the
little details
and the people that pretended to solve
the problem they can maybe go one level
and then they get stuck the president's
first space policy directive to me was
go to the moon and the word in there is
sustainable tell me reusability is
fundamental
um the fully reusable vehicle
will cost 100 times less per flight
than an expandable vehicle it kind of
makes sense think of
uh of any other motor transport it could
be like a
jet aircraft or a cars
bicycles horses every other mode of
transport
boats they're all reusable the
only the weird one that is reusable is
space
that's right so you can imagine how
expensive it would be if every time you
flew in a jet
that you had to get a new jet um as
opposed to refuel the jet
that would be insanely expensive to fly
a jet up with a single use there
wouldn't be anybody flying no exactly
like
we are like a few research flights at uh
at an extreme expense and that's
that's all the flying that would occur i
actually don't care at all about money
at all
but i do care about us becoming a space
spring civilization
yeah and i do know that uh if we don't
uh achieve full and rapid reusability it
will not happen
and so that's why that's the only reason
i actually want money at all
what i really want to see is you know
permanent based on mu
on the moon permanently occupied human
base on the moon
and us building city on mars that's like
i can see the beginning of that before i
die i'll die happy
in creating these companies that we
thought that we would be successful
i thought that the most likely outcome
was failure
but but it was still worth doing even
though the
the odds of success were low in fact
even for for support spacex
the originally what i started doing was
not creating a rocket company but
but actually was going to do a small
mission to mars which was just a
philanthropic mission where you
would send a small greenhouse with seeds
and dehydrated gel
in the wood upon landing hydrate the gel
and you'd have this cool picture of
green plants on a red background
and the public tends to respond to
precedence and superlatives so this will
be the first life on mars furthest that
life's ever traveled
um and you'd have this great money shot
of green plants on the right background
so um yeah i thought that would get
people's attention so
um but but the expectation for that was
was no return so
i thought we wouldn't get any uh you
know we'll just
spend the money on that and it wouldn't
wouldn't happen you want to do some
things that were of
benefit to humanity why why did you
think that
well because not everyone does yeah no i
i guess it was um
i it's sort of a existential crisis uh
of like what does it all mean and what's
the meaning you know what's the meaning
of life and
uh is this 3am over a beer or this was
well more seriously
probably goes back to high school i
guess uh um
i don't want to give a laboriously long
answer but uh
i was uh yeah i had sort of a
dark childhood it wasn't good um
probably partially brought on by by
reading some of the philosophers like
do don't ever read schopenhauer
nietzsche if you're 14. it's
it's not good yeah or ein rand either
too yeah
yeah so um i was just trying to find
figure out what
you know what does it all mean and um
actually
uh when i read the hitchhiker's guide to
the galaxy which i think is a great work
philosophy
um that sort of highlighted the point
that
uh very often the issue is understanding
what questions to ask
and if you can properly frame the
question then the answer is the easy
part
um so i thought things that uh expand
the scope and scale of the human
consciousness
um and allow us to better ask questions
and
you know and and and achieve greater
enlightenment those are good things
and so that's sort of what what can we
do that's going to
um most likely lead to that outcome back
in 95
there weren't very many people on the
internet and certainly nobody was making
any money at all
most people thought the internet was
going to be a fad a year ago
musk sold his software company zip2
which enabled newspapers to
publish online for 400 million dollars
cash receiving cash is cash i mean those
are
just a large number of ben franklin so
this is an atm what we're going to do is
transform the traditional banking
industry
i do not fit the picture of a banker
raising 50 million is a matter of making
a series of phone calls
and the money is there i've sunk the
great majority of of my net worth
into x.com which is the new banking and
mutual funds company on the internet
that i've started
big apps exactly x.com i think x.com
could absolutely be a multi-billion
dollar bonanza
because if you look at the industry that
x is pursuing
it's the biggest sector of the world
economy what you've got going on with
the internet is it's basically
like an earthquake where the epicenter
is silicon valley
and it's it's shaking up the whole world
elon you've you've been compared to
henry ford
richard branson um
you know steve jobs uh who do you
compare yourself to
um i don't really compare myself to
anyone um i mean it's not
um i mean there's certain people that i
admire from history that i think are
you know i think are great um certainly
many of the scientists and engineers and
literary figures and so forth and uh
like i'm a big
big fan of ben franklin you know he was
a
scientist and sort of thinker and i mean
he was kind of guy
who who did did what needed to be done
you know
so guys like that i right i wouldn't say
i compare myself in any way but
i certainly admire them now i've got a
special bonus clip that i think you're
going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video
and what is your specific plan of action
for the next
week when you just watch a video and get
motivated by it you have a 35
chance of following through but when you
get motivated and then create
a specific plan of action you have a 91
chance of following through that's what
we do here believe nation we get
motivated but then we do
something about it and when you commit
to other people you increase your
chances
even further of following through so
what was your biggest takeaway from this
video
and then what is your plan of action
around for this week
put it down in the comments below
because i want to celebrate
you well i think part of the problem the
reason people aren't as excited about
space is that we haven't been pushing
the frontier as much
and so you can only you can only watch
the same movie
so many times and it before it gets a
little boring
um and you know in in this in the 60s
and
early 70s we were really pushing the
frontier of human space flight
and and obviously that those land
landing on the moon is regarded as one
of the greatest achievements of humanity
of arguably of life itself
um and and even though only a handful of
people
went to the moon vicariously we all went
there well at least i wasn't alive at
the time so
but retrospectively um
and you know and it was it was just one
of those really inspiring things that i
think
made everyone glad to be you know human
you know it's like the things that we
where we don't they're bad things human
ideas and they're good things and it's
one of the good things
um and i i do think it's important that
that we have these inspiring things
that uh make you glad to get up in the
morning and
um and that that's uh and
glad to be a member of the human race um
and and and we need to we need to push
that that that frontier
um so um and and i think
uh the great goal we should be trying to
pursue is trying to make life human
like make life multi-planetary so to to
establish a self-sustaining
and growing uh civilization on another
planet uh
mars being the only realistic
possibility um
uh and i think that would just be one of
the greatest things humanity could ever
try to do
if you want to know the five pieces of
life-changing advice from bill gates
check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe
and i'll see you there when you have a
business that's important as this with
this many competitors
you're going to have people saying some
nasty things the thing that was scary to
me wasn't quitting
and starting the company it was when i
started hiring my friends